Thank You Stefan and thank you to the
audience for being here and thank you to
the organizers and thank you to the
staff I'm sure who has been working
really hard to make this happen so
welcome to the final session of the
symposium invisible devoted to projects
that explore the connections between
perspectives human or mechanical
perspectives and the various things that
fly under the radar both because of that
very perspectives limitations on the one
hand and despite its very best efforts
on the other in order to give you a
handy and accessible way to process the
panel you're all about to experience
I want to refashion a popular phrase
that I'm very certain we all know the
phrase is beauty is in the eye of the
beholder and its newly refashioned
version for the sole purpose of making
this panel cohere for you in very brief
form is now the following presto
change-o it's this the visible is in the
eye of the beholder in other words what
the beholder can see is contingent it is
neither absolute nor universal what
counts as worthy of being seen what
counts as necessary to see and where a
seeable thing falls on one's priority
list of things to see our consequence of
how seeing is wielded and who or what is
doing the seeing in the first place
esteemed art critic Jonathan Crary
supplies the basis for this theory when
he reminds us that seeing is susceptible
to the wildly unpredictable foibles of
the human body which houses the
otherwise respectable activity of seeing
and this is what he says from the
beginning of the 19th century a science
of vision will tend to mean in
an interrogation of the physiological
makeup of the human subject rather than
the mechanics of light and optical
transmission it is a moment when the
visible escapes from the timeless order
of the camera obscura and becomes lodged
within the unstable physiology and
temporality of the human body the real
importance of physiology is that it
became the arena for new types of FSM
all at the epistemological
reflection that depended on knowledge
about the eye and processes of vision it
signals how the body was becoming the
sight of both power and truth end quote
and when bodies are socially modified I
like this word socially modified that I
came up with and when bodies are
socially modified with a racial economic
national ethnic sexual or gender
identity
seeing becomes personal and political
indeed customized for the particular
body that the eye is lodged in
literature professor that I am it would
be remiss of me not to offer you a
literary example of what this all means
a literary example of what the
implications are but I won't go the
obvious route via Ralph Ellison's 1952
novel Invisible Man about a black male
protagonist rendered in many ways
invisible by racism instead I'll read
you a brief passage from Toni Morrison's
first novel published in 1970 titled The
Bluest Eye about a young black girl
who's suffering a similar fate firmly
wishes she had blue eyes so that those
who beheld her could discern not only
beauty but also the simple fact that she
was visible in the first place in this
scene that I will read to you
she's at a small shop and about to buy
some candy she pulls off her shoe and
takes out three pennies the gray-head of
mr. yak about ski looms over the counter
he urges his eyes out of his thoughts to
encounter her his eyes are blue eyes
bleed dropped slowly like Indian summer
moving imperceptibly toward fall
he looks toward her somewhere between
retina and object between vision and
view his eyes draw back hesitate and
hover at some fixed point in time and
space he senses that he need not waste
the effort of a glance he does not see
her because for him there is nothing to
see how can a 52 year old white
immigrant storekeeper see a little black
girl nothing in his life even suggested
the feat was possible not to say
desirable or necessary unquote so query
the art critic and Morrison the novelist
encouraged us to ask how does an
investment in yourself as better than
thou deny your eyesight and your
holistic self their ability to realize
their fullest potential how have we been
socialized only to see certain people
certain contingencies or a certain way
of proceeding in life what exactly do we
stand to lose in relegating people
places and things - invisible non
factors indeed - the immaterial in
multiple meanings of that term so while
invisible considers the benefits and
costs associated with the inherent
limitations of our eyes as well as the
limitations we learn to place on them
ourselves it is my hope that the theme
of the invisible will open up the
opportunity
for a scintillating conversation about
the marvels of technology the feats of
the imagination when it compensates for
what we cannot see that would like to
see reified in our lifetimes something
like the imagination as prosthetic eyes
if you will and finally about the
sinister uses of invisible things
created for the express purpose of
blindsiding us in the here and now
making a tomorrow impossible for our
imaginations to even project themselves
into and on that invisibly hopeful note
the presentations will follow the order
listed in the program we'll have
questions at the completion of the three
presentations which begin with Professor
George Barba spaciest thank
[Applause]